yesterday the immigration Minister said
that uncontrolled migration threatens to
cannibalize compassion in this country
by importing different Lifestyles what
do you think he meant by that
what he means is that unprecedented and
uncontrolled illegal migration is
placing uh unacceptable strains and
pressures on communities all around our
country whether it's a hotel which has
now been fully occupied by Asylum
Seekers whether it's
the cost to the taxpayer whether it's
the criminality which is very closely
linked to many people coming here
illegally we see that there are many
people coming here illegally who are
then getting involved in drugs who are
getting involved in violent crime who
are getting involved in prostitution all
of that is at odds with British values
all of that is unacceptable Behavior we
need to deter people from making the
journey in the first place that's why I
encourage everybody to get behind our
measures in the bill so you would think
people that cross-channel and small
boats have different values to the
British public I think people who come
here in a small boat are behaving
unacceptably they should not be getting
in a flimsy plastic dinghy in the depths
of winter
at night putting their own lives at risk
sometimes putting other people's lives
at risk paying thousands of pounds to a
people smuggling gang in the hope of a
life in the UK that is not acceptable
behavior it is breaking our rules it is
abusing the generosity of the British
people and that's why we need to stop
the boats